- We're back and our next guest is one
of the foremost leaders
in the world of fashion.
She's been part of Forbes,
Most Powerful Women,
Time's, Most Influential
and was inducted into The
National Women's Hall of Fame.
Her new book is called "Own
it, The secret to life."
It's out on March 8th
everybody please welcome
Diane Von Furstenberg.
(audience clapping)
(soft music)
Well hello, nice to see you.
Yeah, I see it.
You know what I see also, your love,
that would be my favorite
room in your house.
I love a library.
Is that your office or a library?
- It is my studio.
I have actually been, I'm in the country
and I have been here in
this room for a year now.
- [Kelly] Oh, wow.
- But it's a good room to be stuck in.
- I love that room.
It's inspiring.
I saw it and I was like,
"Oh I wanna just read
and get lost in there."
- Come, come.
- And by the way,
my favorite color is green.
- I know.
- And this is your dress.
- I know, I know.
You look great with leopards all over you.
- I feel like I do too, Diane.
So now, I love it.
I love your wrap dress,
these are my favorite
but I love green, is
also my favorite color.
I just learned that you
do something awesome
with emails every morning.
Can you tell everybody what you do?
- Well, what I try to do
is I try to every morning
to use my magic wand, which
means that with my email
I pick, I do one big email
that totally does not benefit me.
So I may introduce somebody to somebody
that they would never have met
and you could actually
change someone's life.
So I do that.
And it's very interesting because
the more you use your magic wand,
the more powerful your magic wand is.
But very often your magic
wand comes right back to you.
And it becomes a boomerang
- I've never heard of anyone doing that.
And it's so, it's such an
obvious, cool thing to do.
- It's such a good thing to do.
And the reason I like to talk about it
because people get inspired
and then they do it
but you have to do it with care.
- I wanted to talk about that.
'Cause I want people to hear that
and possibly implement
that in their lives.
'Cause that kind of
networking is so beautiful
and those connections are so wonderful.
But I got to talk about your book though,
because you you held it up for us
and the title of your book is "Own It."
So what does owning it mean to you?
- All right,
first of all, when people asked me,
"What did you wanna do when you-",
well, I said I didn't
know what I wanted to do
but I knew the kind of
woman I wanted to be.
I wanted to be a woman in charge.
Then people would say, "Who do you dress?"
And I would say, "The woman in charge."
And then I realized that to be in charge
may sound aggressive, but
really it's not aggressive.
To be in charge is to be who you are,
is owning who you are.
You only perfect your imperfection,
they become your asset.
You own your vulnerability.
It becomes your strength.
And so I decided to
write this little guide
it's really a guide, "Own It"
because owning it is the secret to life.
And then the minute you own
it, you already deal with it.
- Yeah, I love all of that
but Diane said she loves connecting people
and we have an amazing young woman
hoping to change the
world through medicine.
So would you be up for,
I don't know, connecting?
Can I connect her with you?
- I would love them.
- I wanna play fairy godmother today.
I wanna (giggles),
well, I'm gonna hide Diane.
- I play godmother every day.
- I think that's a beautiful thing.
- As you do too.
- I am very fortunate.
I have a lot of people here
helping me with my wand.
So it's amazing what you're
doing all on your own
with your emails.
But we're gonna hide Diane
in our virtual green room
and bring her back to surprise
a very promising young woman.
I'm back,
and my next guest is nothing
short of extraordinary.
She's a high school senior
whose goal is to be a neurosurgeon.
That's crazy.
She recently got accepted
to her dream school
Barnard College in New York city.
But when her family fell
in hard financial times
she actually used the money
she'd saved for college
to pay her mom's rent,
which makes her amazing.
Everybody let's welcome Alondra.
(clapping)
So Alondra, I mean,
we already know you have a heart of gold
from what I just said
but also congratulations on
getting into Barnard college.
That's amazing.
- Thank you so much,
Barnard is my dream school.
I just can't believe I got in.
- Oh my God, it's insane.
And you, I heard you paid your mom's rent
with what you've saved for school, right?
But you still manage to
pay for Barnard, right?
What happened.
- Yeah, so last year in February,
my mom she broke her ankle
and I know it was gonna be hard for her
to get some hours back.
And that was when I just broke down
because I had done everything right.
I got into my dream school
and now I just, I couldn't go.
And that was so heartbreaking
because I knew I had to work so hard
and now it's just my
dream has to stop here.
And it was basically like,
I can't go to Barnard.
Nothing can happen from here.
And so I had been thinking
of making a Go-fund Me
and I told my mom, okay,
you can have my savings.
I told her, we can make up
the money that I gave you.
And so she took it from me
and she was a bit hesitant
but I knew she needed the help.
And then about four days later
I started getting traction,
all the media outlets,
they started sharing it.
And I was just so excited
because everyone was
showing so much stuff.
All the love, we're just so happy.
- What an amazing,
I think that's karma
working at its finest.
Like you did something beautiful
and from your heart and really
was hard for you probably,
you saved that money
for something that was important to you.
And then you set this whole thing up
and look at the universe,
look at God, just giving back.
That's such a beautiful thing.
Well, New York is a big place.
It's a huge, they call
it the Big Apple, right?
So it probably wouldn't hurt
to have some good connections there.
So Alondra, I wanna
introduce you to someone
if that's all right.
She basically knows
everybody who's anybody.
She's a business mogul, a fashion designer
an author and an all around icon.
What I'm saying is she's a
whole lotta woman, Alondra.
(upbeat music)
All right Alondra meet,
Diane Von Furstenberg.
(audience clapping)
She laughed.
- Hi.
- I love that she-
- Hi, so nice to meet you.
- She giggled like a total
score, it was awesome.
- Hello, welcome to Barnard
and welcome to New York.
- Diane is all about
connecting people, Alondra.
And she's just really good at
connecting people she knows
with people who don't know each other.
And the hope is that they
can support one another.
So we wanna do the same, so Diane,
what advice do you have for Alondra?
- All right.
So Alondra,
when you arrive in a new
place like New York city
it's kind of nice to know
that you have a godmother.
It's kind of nice to know
that if anything goes wrong
or not you can always call on someone.
And so I want you to know
that while you are in college
you can call me anytime for anything.
- Thank you so much.
- Alondra, I wish you nothing but success.
And I know that Diane can
help you in any way you want.
And she's just like a
little fairy godmother
when it comes to networking.
And I'm just so proud of you.
I don't know you until now,
but I'm so proud of you like
to have big dreams like that
and really go for it is an
accomplishment in itself
because it can be a scary thing
and especially moving
to a different place.
And I'm just super excited for you, okay.
- I still can't believe I'm even on here.
It's just crazy.
(Kelly giggles)
I was literally crying a week ago
because I couldn't pay for college.
And now I'm on show,
gonna be able to go to my dream school
and I have a mentor.
Oh, I'm so excited.
- I'm telling you what,
if you're a good person,
I think things can happen.
- Dream come true.